ici euh à la
Délégation aux collectivités
territoriales dans un lieu un peu
particulier laïqu républicain mais très
inspirant qui nous amène euh à à penser
que un souffle de pragmatisme
d'intelligence et
d'efficacité ici est assez puissant et
nous sommes heureux de le partager avec
vous je suis très heureuse aussi
d'accueillir parmi nous Mathieu Darnaud
qui a longtemps été membre de cette
délégation il en a même été le premier
vice-président euh en charge euh de la
simplification rôle repris aujourd'hui
par notre collègue Rémy pointerau qui
est le premier vice-président de la
délégation et que je salue et euh
vraiment c'est un plaisir de de vous
rencontrer je suis heureuse que vous
ayez accepté de pouvoir rencontrer euh
les collègues parce que je pense et vous
le savez bien que euh nous avons aussi
beaucoup d'idées euh beaucoup de
convictions nous avons même commis
certaines actions en matière
d'efficacité de l'action publique et
nous serons très heureux de donner aux
collègues l'occasion d'échanger avec
vous donc je ne serai pas très longue
nous avons eu l'occasion avec le premier
vice-président Mathieu Darnaud
d'échanger plusieurs fois avec vous
d'une manière très constructive et je je
vous je je salue votre écoute et votre
état d'esprit que nous partageons
puisque Mathieu Larnaud et moi-même
avons été désigné par le président du
Sénat pour être en quelque sorte la voix
du Sénat à vos côtés donc merci de la
manière dont nous
échangeons je voudrais juste dire
quelques points et vous naturellement
vous laissz présenter votre mission je
pense que nous au Sénat nous ne cessons
de dire non pas parce que nous
radotorions mais parce que nous avons
des convictions et que nous nous pensons
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui chacun peut
le partager après la crise sanitaire que
l'on a v
la crise des gilets jaunes que nous
voyons qu'il y a dans notre pays un
alors on dit un délitement de la société
une perte de confiance et en même temps
une exigence folle de nos concitoyens et
qu'en tout cas quand la ministre madame
goreo était venue devant le Sénat avec
la loi qui s'appelait 3DS
différenciation
déconcentration
décentralisation nous lui avions dit
très aimablement que on l'encourageait à
poursuivre sa lecture de l'alphabet pour
aller jusqu'à la lettre E celle de
l'efficacité de l'action publique
jusqu'au dernier kilomèt parce que je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut plus qu'on
se paye le mot l'enjeu il est là et que
nous n'avons pas besoin de faire de bing
bang territoriaux ou de bing bang
législatif je n'osse pas dire que nous
avons l'essentiel des ingrédients qu'il
nous faut il nous faut juste la volonté
partagée et la détermination d'avancer
et puis à la lettre E il y a aussi la
lettre C on l'a dit pris le mot de
confiance on a un vrai sujet de
doute de de nos concitoyens mais aussi
aujourd'hui de doute de de de ce que
j'appelle les vigil de la démocratie et
les garants de de la proximité de
l'efficacité c'est un doute de la part
des élus locaux qui sont
condamnés à être des inventeurs de
solutions c'est-à-dire chaque jour quand
un mère se lève et va à la mairie euh il
sait pas ce qui peut lui arriver en tout
cas il sait qu'il va avoir une
succession de problèmes et de et de
questions qu'il doit transformer en
solution et on a vu et tout le monde l'a
vu pendant la crise sanitaire que les
élus locaux sont ce que j'appelle des
inventeurs de poss possible qui font que
grâce à eux la la confiance elle reste
elle est UE alors moi je donnerai juste
quelques points dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure il me semble d'abord que les
élus ils ont besoin d'une manière
générale de visibilité de stabilité je
veux parler notamment des finances mais
quand quand je parle de finance je parle
de financement de leur projet vous
pouvez pas aujourd'hui décider de de de
projeter la construction d'une école
quand lorsque vous allez poser la
première pierre les règles de
financement ont changé ou sont
incertaines et que je pense que l'État
doit être dans une logique de
contractualisation avec les
collectivités mais pas la mode de longâ
voilà c'est vraiment dans cette idée
d'un préfet ou d'un sous-préfet qui va à
la rencontre des élus qui regarde quel
est le projet porté par les élus projet
qui a fait que ces élus ont été élus par
le leurs concitoyens donc à partir de
projet de territoire la deuxième chose
c'est que il faut que l'État se détende
c'est-à-dire que l'État continue à
vouloir porter des choses qu'il peut pas
porter parce qu'il est trop lourd trop
loin et cetera donc c'est cette idée
faisons confiance au sens de la
responsabilité des élus et donnonsleur
dans un cadre d'unicité de la la
République la capacité à agir
finissons-en par les petits points de
décentralisation je prends toujours
l'exemple aujourd'hui assez fascinant
des décennies après la décentralisation
que un gestionnaire de lycée qui exécute
des tâes qui sont sous la responsabilité
du président de région continue à être
un fonctionnaire de l'État et que tout
dépend de sa bonne volonté pour que le
président du département de la région
puisse exécuter les responsabilités
qu'on lui a donné un mot sur la
subsidiarité c'est-à-dire nous nous
pensons que l'efficacité de l'action
publique elle se base sur la
subsidiarité c'est-à-dire permettre que
le meilleur niveau fasse les choses
parfois il faut être à deux et parfois
le niveau est différent et puis un sujet
majeur alors on a eu des collègues je
pense agès caniller rerouche qui ont
fait un rapport sur les services
déconcentrés de l'État parce que je
pense que un sujet dont on parle très
peu parce qu'on parle différenciation
décentralisation c'est la
déconcentration c'estàd que l'État il
doit être au plus près des territoires
le préfet doit être le chef d'orchestre
des services et des agences qui
dépendent de l'état l'État doit parler
d'une voix et moi j'ai encore un exemple
récent d'une ARS où il y a des gens
extrêmement compétents qui ont une
manière de voir les choses dans ligne
ance des des
élus sans coordination avec le préfet et
que ça crée des difficultés à tous et
que les préfets doivent
être des des comment dire il doivent
assurer un service après vente de la loi
et faire connaître aux élus les
possibilité qui existe parce que ici
même nous avons réalisé que les maires
ne connaissaient pas les libertés que
nous avions donné n'est-ce pas Mathieu
dans la loi 3DS et que les rescrits que
nous nous avons enfin rendu possible je
crois qu'il y en a pas eu 10 de de fait
parce que un préfet n'a pas de liberté
sur le pouvoir règlementaire ce qu'il ne
peut le faire qu'à partir d'une
autorisation de son administration
centrale et je pense que
l'administration centrale aime assez
l'uniformité n'aime pas s'aventurer dans
des choses un peu à risque voilà moi
j'en est terminé euh voilà Mathieu tu
veux peut-être dire un mot et puis après
cher on vous laisse la parole et puis
surtout les collègues aont sûrement de
multiples
questions merci cher Françoise merci de
de cette
invitation pour moi grand plaisir que de
revenir à la à la délégation et de
poursuivre les échanges que nous avons
régulièrement maintenant avec le kesteur
Eric vert qui est chargé d'une mission
qui est à mon avis essentielle et comme
je me fais souvent sermonnner par
Françoise parce que je dis ce qui ne va
pas je veux dire très directement à Eric
vert que la philosophie avec lesquel il
aborde cette mission me semble aller
vraiment dans le bon sens en épousant
notamment la philosophie que nous
portons ici au Sénat philosophique je
peux résumer en un mot pour nous
aujourd'hui il faut revenir à une
territorialisation de l'action publique
qu'est-ce que c'est que la
c'est finalement s'inspirer de ce que
sont les ressort de nos différents
territoires pour écrire finalement le le
fonctionnement euh et mettre en place
les les outils qui permettent finalement
de répondre à ce que doit être en tout
cas pour la plupart d'entre nous
l'action publique c'est-à-dire répondre
aux aspirations de de nos concitoyens
pour ce faire nous avons fait des
propositions très clair dans nos
différents rapports que ce soit le
groupe de travail sur la
décentralisation le rapport sur l'avenir
l'avenir du maire considérant que pour
nous le point de départ de l'action
publique c'est le maire et je pense
qu'il faut réinvestir ce ce sujet que
c'est par la même que nous redonnerons
un peu de liberté pardon de le dire
aussi directement mais un peu
d'espérance
pour une grande majorité je le dis
aujourd'hui de mer nous avons rencontrer
sur l'ensemble des territoires qui se
désespèrent d'avoir finalement ce ce
sentiment de ne plus servir à
grand-chose de n'être que le réceptacle
des mots de la société et singulièrement
euh des mots qui traversent euh leur euh
leur communees et les problématiques de
euh leurs des concitoyenes des
concitoyens qui qui vivent dans dans
dans ces communes pour se faire nous
semble aussi euh très directement qu'il
faut peut-être redonner un petit peu de
liberté dans l'organisation du bloc
communal il nous semble et c'est pas une
atteinte que je porte ou euh une énième
critique à l'endroit de la loi notre
mais d'avoir voulu euh rendre
obligatoire le transfert d'un certain un
nombre de compétences peut correspondre
à certaines réalités et peut euh
déboucher sur des disfonctionnement dans
dans d'autres territoires je pense
notamment à celle des intercommunalités
qu'on a communément appelé XXL les
grandes intercommunalités et nous en
avons visité beaucoup là encore sur tous
les territoires donc le propos qui est
le mien il est avant tout le reflet des
retours d'expérien que nous avons eu et
je le dis très directement euh notamment
dans dans dans la somme monsieur saumon
nous avons rencontré beaucoup
d'intercommunalités où on a dans ce
département par exemple une
intercommunalité de 119 communes avec
une centralité de 2500 habitants on
comprend les difficultés pour pour
fonctionner des communautés XXL je crois
qu'à part le grand reince où on a eu
plutôt eu un satisfait site dans la
façon dont dont tout ça fonctionne avec
une charte et le sentiment que chaque
élu a a son mot à dire on s'aperçoit
qu'un peu partout ailleurs c'est quand
même compliqué ça c'est la première
chose ch et puis euh finalement le le
pendant c'est l'organisation de l'État
et je fais bien les propos que que
François a tenu je crois qu'il est
urgent d'avoir une déconcentration qui
est aboutie qu'est-ce qu'une
déconcentration aboutie c'est un préfet
qui est coordonnateur de l'ensemble des
services de l'État alors il peut être
décisionnaire ou coordonnateur je pense
notamment à des services comme l' RS
comme l'éducation nationale où on sait
la complexité que cela revê les
difficultés qu'il y a à coordonner ou à
à décider mais je crois qu'il faut et et
je prends toujours un exemple à dessin
je me suis ému de voir que le Premier
ministre sur les barrages face aux
agriculteurs disait qu'il allait euh
demander au préfet de jouer un rôle au
niveau de de l'ofb ça fait 3 ans euh
qu'au travers de la loi 3DS nous avons
fait des préfets de département et c'est
une euh marque du du Sénat euh les
délégués départementaux de l'Office
français de la biodiversité or on voit
bien et ça traduit ce que disait
Françoise que les préfettes et les
préfets n'ont pas encore le réflexe de
se saisir de l'ensemble des prérogatives
qui sont les leurs et qu'il qui serait à
mon sens euh en capacité de de faciliter
le le travail des élus et puis de la
simplification disons-le très clairement
alors c'est un vieux serpent de merde
parler de simplification mais la réalité
elle est pourtant assez simple je crois
que et je le dis très directement alors
mon propos ne plaira peut-être pas à
tout le monde mais je pense que l'État
elle doit être incarnée sur un
territoire c'est les préfets les
sous-préfets moi je pense que la
multiplication des agences
l'agencification de l'État c'est une
façon de parasiter euh l'œuvre qui doit
être celle de l'État déconcentré sur les
territoires entre les actions cœur de
ville les petites villes de demain les
villages et demain les hameau du futur
je pense que non mais il y a un moment
on le dit mais il faut à un moment donné
Françoise parlait du e de les efficience
l'efficience c'est aussi comprendre
comment ça fonctionne sur les
territoires on l'a dit mais je crois que
là-dessus on a la même philosophie cher
Eric vert sur les dotations là encore Dr
dcil fond vert alors qu'on sa'est toutes
et tous ici parce qu'on l'a tous
pratiquer que quand on peut pas avoir de
la DETR ben le préfet ou le sous-préfet
il oriente sur de la décile et quand la
décile est vide on on voit comment on
peut bidouiller le dossier pour que on
puisse vous octroyer du fond vert ben je
pense qu'il faut aller directement au
but ayant une dotation avec une
programmation pluriannuelle parce que
les maires veulent aussi de la
visibilité ils n'en peuvent plus d'avoir
à gérer chaque année un budget en ayant
que des inconnus et pas de certitude
donc voilà revenir à des fondamentaux
revenir à une action de l'État
territorial nous nous sommes d'ardent
défenseurs ici au Sénat de de l'État
territorial parce que les préfets
doivent être ses ensembliers les
sous-préfets sont ceux qui sont à
l'écoute des maires des élus des
intercommunalités et qui permettent
justement tous ces tous ces ajustements
qui permettent surtout de de répondre à
ce besoin d'efficience et plus
généralement de confiance parce qu'il y
a quand même un vrai sujet de confiance
sur sur nos territoires donc cette
territorialisation de l'action publque
c'est ça c'est finalement redonner à
chaque territoire de France la
possibilité à nouveau je dirais pas de
de réenchanter mais mais de retrouver
une
forme une capacité de répondre aux
aspirations de nos concitoyens et un
dernier mot parce que ça c'est vraiment
une ligne rouge pour le Sénat et nous
l'avons dit redit il faut éviter de
verser dans le droit d'exception je
pense qu'à un moment donné il faut qu'on
ait une ligne claire si on doit aborder
le sujet de l'Alsace abordons le sujet
de l'Alsace mais disons les choses très
clairement évitons pardon de le dire de
refaire ce qu'on a fait dans 3ds avec le
volet marseillais qui a généré du droit
d'exception c'est-à-dire qu'on a une
métropole qui ne fonctionne pas avec les
mêmes règles du jeu pour la faire courte
que d'autres territoires je pense qu'à
un moment donné malheureusement on va
finalement vendre un pays à la découpe à
force de de de générer ce droit
d'exception et on va rajouter du trouble
au trouble nous on veut de la clarté on
veut que finalement les règles du jeu
elles soient un peu partout pareil et
qu'on arrête de contourner euh le le le
sujet quand on a des problématiques qui
relèvent d'une spécificité territoriale
on doit pouvoir se dire des choses euh
sans que ça contrarie l'édifice la règle
la règle commune voilà euh je veux pas
être plus long j'ai déjà été beaucoup
trop long euh comme le dit souvent le
président Larché euh tout est dans les
étagères les multiples rapports dont
Françoise a encore fait ce matin la
promotion et dont nous ne cessons euh
euh de de dire qu'ils sont pour nous
avant tout le reflet de ce qu'on entend
régulièrement sur les sur sur les
territoires hein sur l'avenir du maire
notamment avec toutes les contributions
qu'on a pu avoir dans dans les
différents départements régions euh et
puis les outils qu'on a utilisé pour
mener à bien ces ces missions voilà ce
que je souhaitais dire et en remercier
encore Eric vert parce que il est très
très très souvent à l'écoute des des
propositions sénatoriales et encore une
fois je dis sa
philosophie épouse vraiment les les
orientations que nous avons souhaité
donner à nos à nos rapports et à nos
missions
sénatorial merci Monsieur le
vice-président cher Mathieu monsieur le
ministre
chri voilà la parole est
V madame la Présidente chère Françoise
monsieur le Premier vice-président du
Sénat mon le premier vice-président de
la délégation mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs merci d'abord de de de
m'inviter je suis pas venu tout seul
parce que vous êtes quand même très
nombreux et très compétent donc j'ai
besoin de m'entourer par une partie
d'une équipe une équipe de pour un
parlementaire en mission qui a été un
peu étoffé donc on si ou SEP personnes
qui qui viennent des inspections ou de
la Cour des comptes ou du du Conseil
d'État parce que c'est une vision
panoramique et
que vous le savez parfaitement bien dans
cette délégation et il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de volontarisme mais il y a
aussi beaucoup de droit beaucoup de
constitution beaucoup d'environnement
financier et donc on a besoin dans des
conclusions qui peuvent être les nôtres
d'avoir bien regardé la faisabilité non
pas uniquement politique elle est
fondamentale mais aussi la
faisabilité juridique et si s'il y a des
difficultés d'essayer de les de les de
les lever
donc je je je partage évidemment ce qui
a été dit le président de la République
m'a confié une mission qui une mission
large et je vais vous donner des
éléments peut-être en un quart d'heure
20 minutes et puis après je sais pas
jusqu'à quelle heure on a
mais je répondrai soit aux
questions je suis en cours de travail
donc je je vais pas vous apporter de
solution donc je suis en cours de
travail nous avons comme commencé en
décembre nous nous délivrerons des
conclusions au président au fur et à
mesure mais on en délivrera des
définitives en ce qui concerne la
mission après c'est le gouvernement de
de de choisir ou pas de le transformer
en un ou des textes de loi qui peuvent
être d'ailleurs de nature différent
et donc on cette réunion elle est aussi
pour pour nourrir ce ce travail et
écouter également évidemment bien sûr ce
que vous avez à dire mais comme on est
déjà début février évidemment on a on a
des pistes et je voudrais un peu vous
dire dans quel cadre on on travaille
d'abord il s'est dit beaucoup de choses
Françoise l'a dit et Mathieu également
il s'est dit beaucoup de choses tout
particulièrement au Sénat évidemment un
peu moins à l'Assemblée un peu mais mais
moins à l'Assemblée il y a beaucoup de
rapports et si jamais on en oublié un
Françoise Gattel m'écrit pour m'envoyer
la liste des rapports disponibles et
également une synthèse si jamais j'avais
pas envie de les lire mais c'est
difficile d'échapper à un rapport
sénatorial sur le sujet
il y a des rapports très très précis des
rapports plus généraux et le Sénat a
synthétisé en fait assez bien ses ses
propositions il y a aussi des
propositions de loi qui sont en cours ou
qui vont être lancées euh moi je on me
dit comment ça s'articule bah ça
s'articule pas parce que les assemblées
sont évidemment et je je je serai le
dernier à dire le contraire libre de de
déposer les propositions de loi qu'elle
le souhaite et et et et les mettre à
leur ordre du jour mais mais tout ça
s'articule d'abord parce qu'on se parle
et puis que tout ça c'est c'est c'est au
même moment en fait c on on est on est
au premier semestre il est également il
y a également des travaux qui ont été
réalisé en dehors en dehors et qui sont
nécessaires par les associations de
d'élus que vous connaissez parfaitement
bien et je vais pas vous les décrire
nous les voyons régulièrement nous on
travaille sur plusieurs éléments d'abord
le le
financement c'est mon tromis unthopisme
le le financement j'ai moi j'ai bien
compris
que on aimerait bien retrouver un lien
direct entre le contribuable et et le
citoyen local euh ce lien il a été rompu
au fur à mesures d'abord pour les
entreprises par la taxe professionnelle
euh j'étais ministre du Budget à
l'époque donc je prends ma part de
responsabilité ça fait l'objet de
beaucoup beaucoup de débats pour les
sénateurs les plus anciens et assez
épiques ici euh ça a abouti un système
qui n'était pas tout à fait idéal mais
qui était un peu meilleur enfin bref ça
a quand même conduit un peu par la CVAE
par exemple à éloigné assez
considérablement du du territoire
lui-même euh et et il y a un nouveau
changement c'est qu'il y aura plus de
CVAE alors il y a encore une part mais
il y aura plus de CVE le deuxième point
c'est qu'il y a plus de taxe
d'habitation alors on peut le regretter
mais on va pas refaire le débat cétait
voté j'avais ma ma propre position elle
est publique elle est dans les
contte-rendus de l'Assemblée donc moi je
pars de cet aspect très concret je un
bon courage pour celui qui a envie en
réalité pas uniquement sur un dans un
collocque ou dans un tracte de dire je
je vais rétablir un impôt une
contribution universelle bon à un moment
donné c'est la même personne qui
s'appelle un électeur ou un citoyen qui
va sortir des euros de sa poche que ça
s'appelle contribution de truc ou taxe
de résidence ou ou autre chose ce sera
bien quelque chose qui sera pris dans sa
poche et on lui aura expliqué l'État
lui-même mais au fond à un moment donné
les élus également qu'on qui pit moins
d'impôts donc c'est c'est pas si simple
et je pense que c'est assez
contradictoire et je pense que notre
crédibilité globale soit de droite de
gauche dans la majorité ou pas dans la
majorité on s'en prendra plein la figure
et au fond assez à juste titre ce serait
le plus simple c'est pas compliqué de
créer un impôt hein vraiment c'est on a
vraiment des grands spécialistes partout
donc c'est pas compliqué comment on fait
si on s'empêche cela moi je vous parle
de ma position ne vaut que pour cette
mission aujourd'hui et et bien
évidemment rien de ce que je vais vous
dire n'a été tranché par le le président
lui-même euh nous nous pensons qu'il
faut euh utiliser la fiscalité donc
nationale la fiscalité qui existe euh
donc cette fiscalité nationale on est en
train de la regarder de façon évidemment
euh très proche pour essayer de regarder
quelle fiscalité nationale pourrait être
utilisée à quel euh sur quel strate de
de collectivité euh locale euh ayant un
lien avec une disons les charges
prépondérantes ou ou majoritair de cette
même collectivité comment essayer de
territorialiser cette fiscalité locale
comment essayer d'en définir des règles
de partage qui ne soient pas des règles
de dépendance entre un état
tout-puissant et un PLF qui dicterait
année après année les conditions de ce
partage mais entreego c'est la c'est
c'est la territorialisation de l'action
publique de de Mathieu comment on
territorialise au fond l'impôt et donc
la capacité aussi de décider sur une
fraction d'impôt national on est entre
ég l'impôt finance à la fois des
politiques nationales et à la fois des
politiques locales l'unité de l'État
n'en est pas pour
autant affaiblie cette unité de l'État
nous ne sommes pas dans un état fédéral
j'apprends absolument rien à personne
donc les collectivités c'est l'État a la
compétence de sa propre compétence et
les collectivités locales au fond
exercent à un moment donné parce que le
législateur le décide donc inf finé les
institutions de de l'État donc tout cela
doit reprendre sa place et également
dans le domaine du financement et dans
le domaine des dotations ce qui est très
important c'est que il y ait euh pas de
fléchage de dotation inutile euh que on
puisse peut-être consolider le grand
bloc de dotation de d'investissement ou
de ou de ou d'équipement il y a toute
une série hein vous les connaissez la
DSU la DETR le FNADT enfin tout ça c'est
pour de bonnes raisons le fond vert un
certain nombre de dotations issu des des
agences euh comment on fait pour essayer
de globaliser ces dotations et puis
avoir un dialogue local pour la
distribution de ces dotations qui
pourrait prendre d'ailleurs sur une
partie de pluriannualité parce que les
maires ont souvent ou les EPCI ont
souvent des des projets pluriannuels qui
demandent une garantie de financement
sur quelques sur quelques années on
pourrait aussi sur le plan national
contractualiser au mieux au travers
d'unun d'une loi de programmation alors
elle peut être changé tous les ans mais
au moins à moitié du mandat municipal
c'estàd à peu près tous les 3 ans avoir
une contractualis une une loi de
programmation qui fixerait les grandes
enveloppes et la la manière de faire
puis a une gouvernance du système
évidemment à partir du moment où on
partage les choses il y a une
gouvernance du système il faudra
toujours un peu de TVA pour tout vous
dire parce que sinon ça tourne pas
mais mais mais mais voilà en quelques
mots le deuxième élément c'est c'est
c'est la clarification
l'approfondissement des des compétences
la première des clarifications ce serait
d'abord de respecter la loi c'est-à-dire
que les collectivités fassent ce
qu'elles doivent faire et pas
plus ça a été 1000
fois fait fait 1000 fois l'objet de
débat seu la commune a une compétence
générale clause de compétence générale
les départements non et et la région non
et les EPCI c'est des EPCI donc on a
besoin d'essayer d'abord de clarifier
les choses tout le monde fait
tout alors indirectement d'abord les
crises font que tout le monde fait tout
parce que dans la crise au fond c'est
celui qui saisit l' premier du sujet qui
qui qui réussit et d'ailleurs euh et
d'ailleurs l'état estant dans la dans la
machine il se fait également mais mais
le pays ne vit pas tout le temps en
crise et au fond si on arrive à avoir
une organisation naturelle de crise
efficace en fond pourquoi pas euh mais
mais en dehors de ça et heureusement on
n'est pas tout le temps en crise on a
besoin de de faire en sorte que chacun
respecte un peu les lois qu'il a
lui-même d'ailleurs parfois voter au
Sénat ou à l'Assemblée euh quand il y a
une compétence économique bah elle est
affectée notamment au à la région et aux
EPCI bah on respecte cela parce que ça
veut dire que la il y a toujours une
bonne raison d'intervenir toujours
toujours toujours toujours et il y a
toujours une bonne raison pour dire oui
mais l'autre il fait pas mêle-toi de tes
propres affaires ne t'occupe pas de la
la collectivité d'à côté euh ou t'occupe
pas de de l'État euh lui-même donc il y
a toujours une bonne raison et
évidemment l'argent qui qui est mis
c'est autant d'argent qui n'est pas mis
sur les compétences obligatoires du même
niveau de collectivité donc comment on
peut clarifier tout cela sans tomber
dans la
brutalité est-ce que d'abord c'est
vraiment
clair les départements au travers de de
de l'aide aux
communes rebascule un peu tout d'une
certaine manière donc on doit faire
attention à tout çaa les régions comme
elles sont très loin mais elles existent
politiquement les présidents de région à
peu près existent tou même parfois très
fortement politiquement c'était pas le
cas dans dans des régions plus petites
mais les conseils régionaux n'existent
pas ou ou pas bien puisqueils sont pas
territorialisés bon donc ils ont besoin
d'exister donc il y a il y a des projets
qui sont de plus en plus territorialisés
alors que c'est plutôt de la plutôt le
département qui devrait faire ou la
commune qu' y a pas de région il y a pas
de raison particulière de d'exercer un
pouvoir ou subventionner tel ou tel
investissement particulièrement
important certes mais enfin très éloigné
de la métropole régionale alors les
collectivités plus petites euh son sont
mieux placé pour le faire donc déjà une
remise en ordre si
possible et la réaffirmation de de de
cela le deuxième élément c'est qu'il
faut approfondir ou clarifier des
compétences déjà existant sur le bloc
sur les départements c'est évidemment la
grande compétence de solidarité c'est la
charge principale et la mission
principale des des départements
budgétairement c'est le cas euh on voit
bien que l'État n'est pas content parce
qu'il considère qu'il paye en grande
partie et que et qu'on reconnaît pas
cela et le deuxième point les
départements considère que l'État il
paye pas ou pas assez ou très peu que ça
s'est amenuisé au fur et à mesure du
temps euh que le retournement fiscal
fait que certains départements sont en
difficulté et qui donc il n'a pas les
moyens d'exercer cette compétence et que
les compensations prévues ne sont pas
les compensations réelles on va pas s'en
sortir dans le système d'aujourd'hui euh
par parce que il y a pas de financement
lié à la solidarité réellement et au
social il y a il y a de la DGF il y a
des partages d'impôts bon tout ça est
mêlé dans des enveloppes bien plus
larges quand on donne une partie des
DMTO au département et on donne une
dynamique très forte alors cette
dynamique quand elle est très très forte
personne ne dit plus rien et puis quand
elle est nettement moins forte ce qui
est le cas aujourd'hui ça évidemment
c'est c'est c'est une difficulté donc on
on réfléchit non pas à reconcentrer et
non pas à recréer les das mais non non
donc non pas à recentraliser mais à
faire en sorte que état et départements
qui doivent collaborer dans les la mise
en œuvre de cette politique efficacité
ce qui compte c'est l'efficacité pour
nos concitoyens je sais pas efficacité
pour le département ou pour le ministre
ou pour le conseiller départemental ou
pour le conseiller régional c'est c'est
c'est pas ça la question c'est comment
on délivre au mieux une bonne qualité de
service public et cette bonne qualité de
service public elle nécessite une
coordination
euh entre l'État et la région sur ce
sujet le département et donc on on
regarde techniquement juridiquement
politiquement comment on peut faire
avoir une proposition qui soit qui soit
efficace sur ce sur ce plan-là après il
y a des régions il y a des des
collectivités qui qui sont pas au bout
de leurs compétences les régions ont été
créées il y a relativement peu de temps
c'est des collectivité locale euh on
voit bien qu'ell cherchent souvent leur
modalité euh d'exercice euh elles font
du train euh bon mais enfin quand le
train est en retard c'est quand même
plutôt la SNCF qui est engueulé euh
elles font plein de choses elles font de
la recherche mais ça c'est très éloigné
euh bon elle elles viennent parfois sur
le réseau routier euh elles sont
autorité organisatrice de de transport
mais mais tout le milieu urbain organise
ses propres transports bon on on voit
bien qu'il y a une recherche les lycées
ça au moins c'est un truc qui est clair
euh mais euh mais euh mais mais
probablement on n'est pas allé au bout
euh de de du fait régional alors on peut
dire on veut pas aller au bout hein
c'est un autre débat mais on peut aller
au bout on peut aller plus loin on peut
aller plus loin sur l'idée que la taille
est très importante pour avoir une pour
que nos concitoyens aent une visibilité
sur l'organisation et sur territoriale
de l'offre de service on peut réfléchir
à la santé on peut réfléchir à
l'enseignement supérieur on peut
réfléchir à plein de sujets sur lesquels
il pourrait y avoir que ce soit en
logique avec la philosophie qui a
contribuer le le le le monde politique à
à élargir les frontières des région et
et à leur donner une existence politique
extrêmement extrêmement forte donc on
regarde tout cela en lien évidemment
avec les régions mais pas que qu'avec
les régons puisque c'est c'est c'est
c'est une politique
obligatoirement nationale et puis il y a
Paris lon Marseille c'est-à-dire des une
organisation territoriale alors pour le
moins
exceptionnel très différente pour des
raisons différentes mais souvent pour
des raisons
soit d'aménagement du territoire c'était
c'était Paris l'idée d'un Grand Paris
comme Grand Londres vous souvenez à
l'époque Nicolas Sarkozy bon et puis et
puis Lyon et Marseille dans des
configurations souvent extrêmement
locales avec le poids c'est souvent
beaucoup ça qui explique les choses le
poids des hommes et des femmes en place
à un moment donné qui négocient tel ou
tel point aujourd'hui ça
mécontente alors pas tout le monde ceux
qui ont le pouvoir ne sont jamais
mécontents mais ça mécontente pas mal de
monde quand même notamment souvent le
concitoyen d'une façon explicite ou ou
implicite savoir qui ramasse les ordures
ménagères dans dans Marseille bah c'est
important pour le concitoyen mais en
fait il a du mal à obtenir une réponse
qui répare la route
intracommunale bon c'est on voit bien
qu'il y a des des à à Lyon bah toutes
les communes sont pas dans la métropole
parce que c'est une collectivité locale
et qu'elle a son propre mode électoral
donc comment on fait est-ce qu'on peut
évidemment s'appuyer sur sur le sur les
opinions locales et qui sont toutes très
différentes est-ce qu'on doit y mettre
ou tenter d'y mettre un peu de un peu
d'ordre vu du citoyen c'est ça qui est
important pas vu de l'intérêt de de tel
ou tel élu mais vu du citoyen est-ce
qu'on peut y mettre un peu d'ordre tout
en respectant les particularités local
c'est en tout cas des solutions
différentes en dehors du mode électoral
des trois villes principales euh sur le
sur la sur la règle le pouvoir
règlementaire il existe pour les
collectivités il existe beaucoup
Françoise a cité plusieurs lois il y a
il y a beaucoup de de de de de
possibilités qui sont offertes aux élus
locaux pour réglementer leurs propres
compétenence ça se passe pas comme ça
euh parce que vous-même comme
législateur et et
nous-même à l'Assemblée on a tendance de
plus en plus à préciser les choses parce
qu'on considère que c'est mieux que de
toute façon si on laisse
l'administration préciser elle va
dénaturer le texte donc on commence à
empiéter sur le pouvoir règlementaire
pas grand monde fait respecter la
séparation pouvoir législatif
réglementaire un peu mais mais pas plus
que ça et puis derrière
l'administration continue à préciser ou
corrige les précisions à la marche en
trop le dire enfin bon tout ça crée
quand même un climat de complexité hein
euh assez inoui euh et on en vient donc
à réguler sur le plan national des
choses qui devraient être régulé sur le
plan local donc comment essayer déjà
dans ce grand cycle non pas de l'eau
mais de la loi du règlement comment on
pourrait là c'est plutôt du vieux parce
que on peut pas évidemment encadrer le
législateur de toute façon la
Constitution l' cadre déjà mais ce
serait bien de faire fonctionner la
Constitution et puis derrière avoir un
principe où l'inscrire comment comment
le rendre réel parce que si c'est encore
une fois pour écrire des mots sans
réalité ça n'a pas d'intérêt c'est de
dire que celui qui détient la compétence
détient également le pouvoir de de
réglementation euh réel donc de mise en
fonctionnement et d'organisation en lien
avec l'État quand c'est nécessaire
et évidemment s'il est en carence il ne
le fait pas pour 1000 raisons
électorales ou parce qu'il a pas il peut
pas il sait pas il fait pas il y a
évidemment un état derrière qui reprend
ce qui n'a pas été fait donc l'État
garant garanti de l'équité entre entre
de service public enfin la subsidiarité
et la contractualisation moi je suis
très favorable à la contractualisation
pas au schéma dans tous les sens pas
mais la
contractualisation vous connaissez les
contrats de plan état région c'est c'est
c'est très ancien euh grosso modo ça
marche pas pas tout le temps et pas
partout mais c'est quand même grosso
modo ça marche d'abord ça ça perdure
donc c'est que ça marche ça veut dire
qu'on se met d'accord c'est aussi aussi
bête que ça mais on se met d'accord sur
un sur un objet précis avec des chiffres
avec des avec des investissements donc
comment on pourrait faire une
contractualisation alors obligatoire
obligatoire parfois je vous donne par
exemple un exemple quand une métropole
fait x % de la taille d'un département
20 30 40 je ne sais pas enfin fait un
point très important dans le département
honnêtement faut quand même qu'il a une
contractualisation entre le département
et la métropole quoi pour savoir qui
fait quoi alors la loi 33ds permet après
des délégations donc on a plein
d'environnements législatifs qui peut
être utilisé dans dans ce cadre là mais
il faut quand même qu'on s'explique
parce que ce qui est fait dans la
métropole à un moment donné a des des
répercussions sur des gens qui n'y sont
pas mais mais qui qui qui sont dans le
même département donc si si chacun au
mieux vit de son côté ou de temps en
temps si si si si les gens travaillent
ensemble tout va très bien enfin en
général ou souvent pas et à ce moment-là
compétition devient très inefficace pour
la production du service public donc je
ne mets pas ou je ne proposerai pas de
contenu à à ces contrats mais mais nous
proposerons l'obligation de
contractualiser c'estàdire de bien
regarder entre les transports on voit
bien le type de service qui devrait être
contractualisé on peut y réfléchir
entre l'État et entre les régions et et
les département particulièrement sur
l'application des politiques économiques
euh les départements
Meur d'envie de faire de l'économie ils
n'en ont pas le
droit donc comment on fait pour pour
trouver sa place au département sans
qu'il empiète non plus ni sur les
métropoles ni sur les épc sinon tout le
monde faire l'économie et personne n'en
fait de l'aide aux entreprise tout le
monde en crise tout le monde en fait
dans n'importe quelles condition donc
comment on peut tenter de de clarifier
et évidemment les régions peuvent
exercer d'autres compétences je l'ai dit
enfin sur la subsidiarité les EPCI je
m'arrête là c'est sans doute un des
éléments les moins clairs mais c'est
tant mieux il s'est différenciant les
EPCI il y a tous ceux qui s'y trouvent
très très bien en général ceux qui sont
président ou vice-président puis tous
ceux qui considèrent qu'il subissent la
loi d'un EPCI alors que ce sont eux qui
sont élus sans doute par une
clarification juridique de la notion de
PCI
entraînant entraînant une réduction du
nombre de compétences
obligatoires vraiment les compétences
doivent être obligatoires lorsqu'on
considère notamment que l'intérêt
national est en jeu par par exemple sur
l'eau l'intérêt national est en jeu on a
peut-être pas tout à fait enfin ici oui
mais nos concitoyens n'en ont peut-être
pas toujours l'impression c'est plus
uniquement de poser des canalisations et
de de et de rendre une eau propre c'est
plus que ça c'est la ressource en eau
c'est la capacité pour la France à
maintenir cette ressource à la fois et
pour tous les usages de consommation
donc c'est c'est un vraiment un point
important et ce qui ferait bien être
l'idée de subsidiarité d'ailleurs à
l'intérieur des EPCI en réinter comme on
dit aujourd'hui on réarme et en
réinterroge en réinterrogeant la notion
de PCI pas pour la détruire pas pour
l'affaiblir pas pour affaiblir la
mutualisation il y a des acquis parfois
obtenus dans le sang mais il y a des
acquis mais en donnant plus de liberté à
cette belle notion d'intercommunalité je
m'arrête j'ai pas parlé de l'exercice du
mandat mais mais mais il y a beaucoup de
choses
là-dessus merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre je trouve que c'est une parole
que je qualifierai volontiers de de
sénateur
sachant que vous avez voulez vous me
voulez du mal là oh sachant que vous
avez satisfait une très grande attente
du premier vice-président puisque vous
avez parlé de l'eau et de
l'assaainissement il n'y a pas de
réunion sénatoriale sans que nous ne
parlions alors il y a cinq prises de
parole mes chers collègues à
minima je sais
que Monsieur le Ministre ve a un
entretien important au Sénat dans la
prolongation
des nôtres à 11h donc si chacun peut
être concis voilà alors dans l'ordre des
inscrit monsieur le Premier
Vice-Président ensuite Monsieur Olivier
Pacco monsieur Pierrejean Rochette
monsieur Cédric chevalier Monsieur
Patrice jolie mais les questions sont
aussi ouvertes aux femmes exactement
Céline excuse-nous
Céline voilà donc monsieur le Premier
Vice-Président Céline pardon oui
merci présidente monsieur le ministre
merci pour vos vos propos liminires et
merci de de votre
présence simplement une question qui n'a
pas forcément été
évoquée très précisément c'est la
préoccupation pour les élus locaux du
poids des normes euh c'est un sujet sur
lequel le Sénat travaille depuis 2014
puisque c'est là où on a été créé donc
une spé spécificité au niveau de la
délégation sur le la simplification
administrative et depuis ce temps on
travaille sur la simplification et le
poids des normes il y a pas que dans
l'agriculture qui a beaucoup de de
normes il y en a aussi beaucoup dans les
collectivités et on avait donc parmi les
les contributions significative au Sénat
on avait fait figurer la création du
pouvoir de dérogation aux normes par les
préfets
et c'est vrai que ça peut être une
source de différenciation puisque ça
permettrait au préfet de de pouvoir
déroger un certain nombre de de sujets
euh euh normatifs et aujourd'hui euh on
voit bien
que l'ancienne premère ministre l'a
signalé d'ailleurs le en mai 2023 euh le
faible usage euh de ce pouvoir de
dérogation voilà alors je voulais savoir
simplement si vous vous avez dans vos
réflexions mis en place un système qui
permettrait de faciliter ce pouvoir de
dérogation les préfets sont assez
frileux aussi faut le dire problème
peut-être de notation et de leur
carrière à venir donc je pense que c'est
un sujet qu'il faudrait sur lequel il
faudrait à mon avis
être plus plus vigilant et essayer de de
forcer un petit peu la main des préfets
pour ces dérogations qui sont souvent
nécessaires notamment pour les dans les
départements ruraux disons merci
beaucoup cher Rémi je passe la parole à
Olivier Pacco et si vous êtes d'accord
cine brullin ayant demandé la parole en
même temps que son voisin je permettrai
un
rattrapage voilà donc
Olivier ensuite Pierre Jean Rochette et
Céline brullin je propose trois
questions voilà donc Olivier puis
Pierrejean euh Éric de te laisser la
parole enfin je vous laisse vous
organiser voilà Olivier en tout cas
merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre cher Éric vert
chers collègues de loise j'ai bien
entendu votre
présentation j'ai bien compris que la
base de vos réflexions portait d'abord
sur les problématiques de financement
puis euh de clarification des
compétences au sujet des problématiques
de financement j'étais assez surpris de
vous entendre au sujet des réformes de
la taxe professionnelle et la taxe
d'habitation dire qu'en fait elles
étaient pas vraiment satisfaisantes et
c'est vrai elles ont été fait un petit
peu à la V vite sans étude d'impact bon
et donc ce que vous avez dit quand même
c'est que elles sont pas satisfaisantes
mais reviendra pas en
arrière deuxième chose concernant la les
compétences vous souhaitez une
clarification vous avez utilisé le mot
remise en ordre et vous avez défini dans
votre logique le fait qu'il faillait pas
qu'il y ait de dépassement de fonction
vous avez évoqué un point très précis
que dans l'Oise nous connaissons bien
c'est l'aide aux communes départemental
j'ai cru comprendre que vous y êtes
opposé bon vous préciserai mais bon ça
m'a beaucoup
surpris j'ai ensuite quelques petites
questions très
précise le Sénat dont vous avez évoqué
la qualité des travaux via ses rapports
a voté il y a pas tellement longtemps je
crois que c'était au mois de décembre le
rétablissement de la réserve
parlementaire est-ce que ça vous semble
une bonne idée une mauvaise idée vous
n'avez pas évoqué la notion de
conseiller territorial qu'en pensez-vous
vous qui avez été conseiller régional de
Picardie en ce qui concerne
l'intercommunalité et je terminerai par
là vous avez dit il y a des EPCI où on
s'y sent bien d'autres où on s'y sent
pas bien il y en a de moins en moins on
se sent bien il y a une forte
désillusion intercommunale lié notamment
à ce que vous avez évoqué le fait que on
soit allé certainement parfois trop loin
dans la l'attribution de compétence ou
la prise de compéten vous avez évoqué la
réduction du nombre de compéten
obligatoirees en parlant notamment de
l'eau et là moi je pense que Mathieu est
peut-être pas sur la même longueur
d'onde parce que nous au Sénat on était
plutôt favorable à une comp
FA et non pas obligatoire parce que
quand ça fonctionne bien quand il y a
des petits syndicats entre guillemets
des fois un peu plus grand au niveau
territorial qui fonctionne très bien
pourquoi casser ces
Bell machin entre guillemets qui ne
coûte souvent pas grandchose
voilà et
ensite je t'en prie
merci de tant de sollicitudes merci
présidente ça va peut-être pas durer
après ce que je vais vous avoir dit
mais merci pour cet
échange vous avez évoqué la disparition
de la clause de compétenence générale
pour les départements et les régions qui
semblent désormais communément admis
admis moi ça m'interroge quand même
parce que je trouve que la clause de
compétenence générale est quand même un
moyen
de permettre à chaque collectivité la
différenciation nécessaire dans le cadre
républicain et en plus je trouve que je
vais le dire de manière caricaturale
mais d'arriver à des collectivités qui
en
gros assument des missions que l'État ou
le législateur leur confie avec les
moyens financiers qui leur
consent ça a tendance à un peu
uniformiser les politiques menées
alors on peut penser ça n'est pas mon
cas mais on peut penser qu'à chaque
problème il y a une unique solution mais
pour moi la politique c'est précisément
que face à un diagnostic partagé ou pas
du reste il y a des
options que les citoyens et les
électeurs en locurrence tranche et
j'entends qu'il y a un vrai problème de
lisibilité de clarification dans
lesquelles nos concitoyens ne se
retrouvent absolument plus mais pour moi
il est presque aussi dangereux que nos
concitoyens considèent
qu'il n'y a plus aucune différence entre
une collectivité gérée par telle ou
telle parce que finalement bah ell
mettent en œuvre des compétences et
c'est c'est je pense oui dangereux au
plan démocratique et je crois qu'on a
besoin de revivifier les choix
politiques même au sens noble du terme
bien évidemment et même au niveau le
plus local qui soit on a tous en tête le
le faible taux de participation aux
dernières élections municipale
évidemment dans un contexte de crise
sanitaire mais rien ne dit que la
commune va
demeurer un échelon démocratique dans
lesquel nos concitoyens vont avoir envie
de s'investir et je parle même pas des
départements et des régions ça c'est la
première chose la
deuxième je suis intéressée par l'idée
de contractualisation je voudrais vous
interroger sur un petit aspect mais qui
est d'actualité qui est d'une actualité
assez urrente qui est la compétence
partagée sur l'école entre les communes
et l'éducation
nationale alors je crois qu'il n'y a
plus aujourd'hui d'inspecteur d'académie
fort heureusement qui
euh décide de ne plus attribuer de
postes dans une école qu'un maire aurait
décidé de laisser ouverte on n est plus
là mais je suis quand même assez effaré
du drame que suscite chaque année les
mesures de carte scolaire et il me
semble qu'il ne serait pas
complètement
inatteignable qui est un peu plus de
concertation voir que les maires aent un
rôle plus important au moins dans la oui
la concertation sur ces mesures de carte
scolaire moi ça m'affole quand même un
peu que le conseil municipal et son mot
à dire sur l'ouverture et les horaires
d'un bureau de poste ce qui est très
important dans une commune mais pas sur
l'ouverture ou la fermeture d'une classe
alors même que les communes investissent
et même considérablement pour certaines
d'entre elles dans l'école ça m'affolle
aussi qu'on soit pas en situation vous
parlez ça me parle aussi beaucoup de de
de voir les choses de manière
pluriannuelle je pense que les communes
sont en situation peu ou prou de définir
l'évolution des effectifs à venir dans
les petites communes on sait quasiment
auj
à l'unité près combien il y a d'enfants
dans la commune dans les plus grandes il
y en a qui se dotent de dispositifs pour
essayer d'avoir une vision prospective
de tout ça et donc dans des compétences
qui sont partagées de manière très
ancienne entre État et collectivité
est-ce que vous travaillez sur des
pistes de concertation de travail commun
qui permettrait qu'on que cette
compétence soit réellement partagée et
pas que l'État impose en quelque sorte
sorte que vous puissiez peut-être
répondre aux trois questions pour
poursuivre ça te va bien
bien une commission qui est bien
géré c'est marant la commission des
finances à l'Assemblée c'était pas le
cas pour moi
oui je vais prendre par bloc sur le sur
tout ce qui est territorial cumule des
mandats parce que je suis passé dessus
parce que j'ai parlé très vite
évidemment c'est quelque chose qu'on
regarde de très près donc sur les sur
ces deux sujets qui sont un peu dans
l'atmosphère politique du non pas du
moment parce que le conseiller
territorial il est depuis longtemps dans
l'atmosphère politique il est à la fois
enterré et vivant donc le sujet n'est le
sujet est toujours sur la sauf que il y
a des changements assez assez clair vous
les avez bien en tête depuis 2010 il eu
des grandes régions et puis des
redécoupages cantonaux
donc voilà il y a des pour il y a des
contes moi j'ai pas de à ce stade on n'
pas d'opinion on
regarde on est en train de d'expertiser
avec le le ministère de l'intérieur des
des des systèmes électoraux celui de de
2010 ne peut plus fonctionner l'idée
générale étant que s'il y avait un
conseiller territorial il faudrait
évidemment ne pas il faut garder les
cantons parce que si on supprime les
cantons alors qu'on vient de les découp
encore une fois les allers-retours c'est
c'est épouvantable alors je sais bien
que le monde d'avant il est toujours
mieux mais il y a quand même quelques
limites euh et pour le cumule des
mandats c'est un sujet transpartisan
d'ailleurs où il y a beaucoup d'idées
pour la réserve parlementaire non c'est
pas c'est c'est pas mon sujet c'est un
sujet parlementaire euh sur le sur les
sur les préfets euh c'est vrai qu'en en
close miroir il y a un le Matignon donc
c'était ellisabeth borne maintenant
Gabriel Atal a repris le dossier de qui
est celui de la la une plus plus
profonde déconcentration euh et on
aboutit toujours au même sujet qui est
le pouvoir du préfet euh je pense que
làdessus à peu près tout le monde tout
le monde dit ça et à juste titre alors
après quand on a un mauvais préfet on
n'est pas très content mais euh l'idée
c'est quand même d'avoir que des bons
préfets avec un vrai pouvoir qui soit
capable de répondre aux élus euh les
élus eux-mêmes ayant plus de pouvoir et
plus d'autonomie de de gestion donc il
doit s'adapter et donc qui doit pouvoir
notamment gérer toutes les injonctions
contradictoires quand elles sont pas
dans la loi pure et dure il peut pas
dire la loi dit ça mais on va faire
autrement donc on est au au niveau de la
réglementation à moins qu'on noblige le
législateur systématiquement à indiquer
dans la loi dans les lois qui permettent
quelle est la marge de manœuvre qui est
donnée sur le plan local et acquis donc
ça c'est possible mais mais la loi est
la loi euh on donc au bémol près de ce
que je viens de de dire mais le préfet
donc il doit arbitrer et il doit pouvoir
arbitrer sur l'école il doit
arbitrer si le préfet a plus de pouvoir
il a aussi le pouvoir sur le
l'administration de l'éducation
nationale ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui ou très peu le préfet étant
le seul haut-fonctionnaire ayant un
regard
qui quand il a quelqu expérience et
c'est quand même bien a été travaill
avec des élus locaux et donc il a il a
une vision politique au bon sens du
terme une vision politique de son de son
département je parle du préfet de
département
donc aujourd'hui on fait plein de
reproches aux ARS en disant il faudrait
les remettre sous l'autorité du
préfet je sais pas parce que il y a 15
ans on a créé des ARS justement parce
que les préfets n'y arrivaient pas donc
c'est très très bien faire sans arrêt
des marches arrièr mais il y a un moment
donné on progresse pas donc est-ce que
est que les ARS ont bien rempli leur
rôle pendant la crise du covid bon non
enfin oui et non l'ARS elle pouvait pas
les diffuser des masques ou il a pas les
réseaux c'est c'est naturellement les
communes enfin naturellement les
structures qui sont au plus près des des
concitoyens l'ARS elle est faite pour
autre chose donc est-ce que les AR
peuvent aussi et ça c'est question de
domomination au fond de profil de gens
est-ce que les ARS elles peuvent aussi
intégrer cette dimension politique
qu'intègrent les préfets quand une
commune est subventionné euh pour faire
le regroupement pédagogique et ouvrir
des classes nouvelles c'est pas pour
fermer 2 ans après l'ouverture une
classe parce que la démographie n'est
pas là donc tout ça doit être prévu
auparavant et ça c'est un travail très
fort entre les financeurs donc en
général le le Conseil départemental et
la commune elle-même quand on parle
d'une d'un regroupement pédagogique et
puis les l'éducation nationale qui par
principe euh anime la politique et et
l'affectation des des profs et ça
pourrait changer quand même beaucoup de
choses est-ce qu'il faut j'ai parlé de
de de remise en ordre j'ai juste parlé
pas pas pas au sens brutal du terme j'ai
dit que il fallait que il fallait
respecter la loi et il y a des lois de
compéten et ça a fait
suffisamment de de dizaines d'heures de
débat là-dessus et et la loi elle a
tranché sur des compétences entre les
uns et les autres alors faut les faire
évoluer il faut mais c tuit juste pour
éviter que que tout le monde fasse tout
que tout le monde fasse tout parce que
plus personne s'y reconnaît si tout le
monde fait tout mais alors faut surtout
pas qu'il a tant de strat je je vais
vous dire si tout le monde fait tout à
un moment donné le débat sur les strates
il va il va revenir parce que tout le
monde faisant tout tout le monde fait
fait rien en fait et d'ailleurs on voit
souvent des financements croisés dans
tous les sens à un moment donné vous
vous demandez si si serait pas mieux que
que telle collectivité se concentre sur
tel truc et et l'autre sur tel l'autre
chose puis après on assume la
responsabilité donc la loi elle dit que
il y a une clause de compétence générale
pour les communes faut absolument
protéger cette clause parce que c'est
c'est l'élément fondamental de la
démocratie locale le maire est le
représentant de la démocratie locale et
pour le pour nos concitoyens quelle que
soit la taille de la commune au fond il
faut donner au maires notamment dans les
EPCI en train d'y travailler un peu plus
de pouvoir qu'il n en a actuellement sur
les sur les sujets fondamentaux
concernant sa propre sa propre commune
donc on peut pas donner tous les
pouvoirs à tout le monde et tout le
monde et je ne suis pas contre l'idée de
l'aide aux communes par les départements
c'est aussi vieux que les départements
tous les départements font de l'aide aux
communes mais ça peut pas être non plus
la la la la façon de revenir sur des
clauses de compétences générales en
ayant des politiques d'aide au communes
sur telle chose et cetera et cetera en
disant au fond au comine voilà ce que
vous devriez faire alors que c'est pas
la compétence du Département parce que
le législ ateur à considéré que ce
n'était pas de la compétence du
Département et les régions doivent être
traité exactement de la même de la même
manière elles doivent occuper à plein
leurs compétences quand certaines
régions disent ah mais l'état vient
vient vient sur nos brisé en terme de de
développement économique ou que les
départements viennent sur nos briser en
terme de développement économique ou que
les
EPCI bon c'est c'est probablement parce
que la région n'occupe pas totalement sa
compétence la nature ayant horreur du
vide à un moment donné il doit occuper
aussi sa propre compétence et quand on
dit tout ça
euh on a déjà une clarification alors
parfois ça plaît Pasin parce que tout le
monde a envie de faire tout par principe
le président de le le le maire d'une
commune importante le président d'un
département le président d'une région il
voit qu'il y a un manque il a un peu
d'argent il fait il fait de la sécurité
dans les transports il fait et cetera et
cetera et cetera et tout ça hors cadre
ég alors on peut décider que tout le
monde fait tout et l'État aussi et je
suis pas sûr que ça que ça que ça
améliore les choses alors faut pas un
jardin la française pour autant hein on
n'est pas en train de faire un un truc
il faut au contraire beaucoup beaucoup
d'adaptation locale beaucoup mais mais
dans ce dans ce cadre là et et la loi le
permet délégation de compétenence vous
pouvez pas faire vous faites pas on se
met autour de la table et et vous vous
avez une compétence vous la déléguer que
sais-je il y a il y a plein d'outils
pour au fond clarifier et permettre
enfin à chacun d'agir vraiment au plus
proche des des des citoyens enfin en
tout cas j'en suis persuadé sur la sur
la
fiscalité et il y a cette belle notion
de responsabilité c'estàdire que plus
vous êtes nombreux à intervenir à moins
il y a quelqu'un de responsable et je
pense que la qualité du service public
c'est aussi d'avoir une responsabilité
de qui opère ce service public et sinon
ça tombe sur le maire ce pauvre maire il
s'en prend plein la figure surtout donc
donc qui opère ce ce ce service public
c'est très important et on voit bien que
tous les débats qui qui deviennent
malsin à un moment donné c'est parce
qu'on sait plus très bien qui opère le
service public chacun a son petit guide
d'aide
économique vous êtes vraiment très fort
si vous recevez un chef d'entreprise ce
qui doit vous arriver régulièrement une
petite PME qui vous demande comment on
peut l'aider très très fort si vous
arrivez à savoir tout de suite quand
même dé facto qui va pouvoir l'aider sur
tel point et sur quel type d'aide quoi
c'est c'est compliqué parce que si vous
êtes dans une grande un grand PCI vous
avez à peu près tout le monde peut faire
grosso modo quelque chose puis en
réalité ça marche pas parce qu'il rentre
pas dans les critères au fond ça se
termine souvent comme ça donc faisons
quand même très attention à tout ça
parce que c'est c'est notre crédibilité
à tous hein et il y a des il y a
quelques
compétences madame la sénateur trist je
sais pas il y a quelques compétences qui
sont globales le sport la culture le
tourisme n'ont pas été définis par le
législateur peut-être que d'ailleurs
faut pas définir moi je peut-être que
c'est très bien comme ça moi je mais
ouais on pourrait être il y a plusieurs
avis mais moi je trouve que sur ces
points-là en réalité le marché si je
puis dire arrive à arbitrer c'est-à-dire
qu'au fond chacun aide dans le domaine
culturel ou sportif des trucs à peu près
à son niveau vous voyez assez peu de
régions sauvent peut-être électoralistme
aller aider le club de de du fin fond du
du truc SAF mais il va aider le champion
du monde qui qui a besoin de bon donc on
ou le club de de de ligue je ne sais
combien donc on a peut-être ça et sur le
plan culturel bah il y a pas d'orchestre
symphonique dans le PCI euh en général
pas euh sauf si c'est un énorme truc euh
l'Orchestre de Paris mais vous vous
voilà chacun trouve euh le son niveau
d'intervention et au fond c'est c'est
peut-être pas si mal mais mais euh mais
mais après si on me dit le contraire on
peut on peut parfaitement me dire le le
contraire sur la fiscalité moi j'ai pas
dit que c'était euh euh j'ai j'ai pas
dit qu'il fallait pas
euh j'ai fait un constat la taxe
d'habitation été supprimée la taxe
professionnelle dans des conditions tout
ça ext extrêmement différentes a été
supprimé donc on coupe à un moment donné
un peu du lien et beaucoup du lien du du
concitoyen et du contribuable bon moi je
fais ce constat après les débats on fait
l'objet de suffisamment de débat pour
que les positions des uns et des autres
soit soient clair là-dessus mais j'ai
rarement vu beaucoup d'élus dire aux
gens qui reçoivent dans leur permanence
vous inquiétez pas on va rétablir la
taxe d'habilitation
j'ai pas vu beaucoup
beaucoup de gens assumer ça donc ce que
je dis c'est que où on est pragmatique
alors par principe on n'est pas
populiste on n pas démagogique donc on
est pragmatique ça a été fait comme ça
ça a des avantages et des inconvénient
mais ça veut dire qu'il faut changer un
peu la vision qu'on a des ressources des
collectivités locales et ça ne peut pas
être uniquement au fil de l'eau par un
partage de la TVA ça peut pas être au
fil de Lou vous pouvez pas dans toutes
les lois chaque fois qu' se passe
quelque chose on rajoute une part de TVA
avec un état qui a les milliers d'euros
de de de milliards les milliers de de
milliards de de dett qui a donc il faut
il faut changer votre point de vue vous
on a un point de vue sur des boussoles
qui son qui n'existe plus donc comment
on fait et c'est c'est là-dessus que
qu'il y a moins de propositions
d'ailleurs le constat est fait beaucoup
des propositions un peu précises le
Sénat fait des propositions dans son
rapport du mois de de juillet la cour
des comptes fait des propositions nous
on va un peu plus loin quee pour essayer
d'avoir un système qui je l'espère peu
fonctionner dans lequel à la fois les
départements les régions et les communes
ont une part de liberté dans la fixation
de leur fiscalité c'est au fond ce que
chacun demande ce qui me semble assez
naturel mais dans un environnement
fiscal qui existe déjà ça veut dire
aussi que l'État doit faire des efforts
pour que notamment la pression fiscale
n'augmente pas bon c'est c'est tout ça
n'est pas si simple mais mais je je
j'espère en tout cas qu'on aura des
propositions lisibles et qui
conviendront au au aux élus locaux quel
quel qu'il soi voilà ce que je pouvais
dire enfin sur l'eau oui j'ai pris
l'exemple de l'eau parce que s'il y a
bien l'eau c'est de l'environnement
c'est bien un sujet qui qui qui d qui
est un sujet d'intérêt national
d'ailleurs une planification nationale
c'est c'est c'est les sujets
environnementaux il y a des
normes sur la sur voilà il y a des
normes parfois trop et parfois il y a
des normes qui doivent être respectées
et elles doivent être respectées partout
mais moi j'ai pas non plus conviction
moi de toute façon c'est des travaux qui
sont en
cours je viens c'est comme si vous
veniez avec un une mission en train de
en train d'être faite en train de
rédiger donc donc je je on corrige aussi
en temps temps
réel et nous nous sommes à considérer
comme une aide à la proposition monsieur
le ministre le pouvoir de dérogation du
préfet donc dans la dans la
déconcentration ce po de dérogation
aujourd'hui il est factice il existe
mais c'est c'est c'est comme ce que
disait François sur François sur les les
les rescrits tout ça existe mais il
l'applique pas parce que il demande à
l'administration centrale le droit de D
Roger le temps que ça redescende le
problème se pose plus et enfin tout ça
n'a pas d'intérêt mais par ex on
pourrait penser que dans dans la
clarification sur les normes ce serait
trop long mais sur la clarification on
pourrait se dire mais un accord entre un
préfet un préfet puissant donc un préfet
augmenté après une une déconcentration
supplémentaire un préfet qui a le
pouvoir sur des agences également
territorialement où il y a on avec une
suppression des appels à projet par
exemple et ce ce ce préfet avec un
président de de de département un
président de PCI éventuellement un maire
si la commune quand il y a un grand
projet et que ce projet est sans arrêt
remis à plus tard parce qu'on on
réétudie un truc qu'on avait pas vu on
refait C on refait ça sous la pression
des différentes administrations ou la
pression de tous ceux qui n'en veulent
pas et qui font durer s'il y avait un
accord entre un préfet et et un
président
d'exécutif ça ça devrait pouvoir valoir
au fond l'égalité présomption de
l'égalité à un moment donné l'étude de
trop voilà le législateur ne l'a pas
souhaité et et dans le règlement ou dans
la règle il y a suffisamment d'éléments
d'interprétation pour considérer écoutez
basta on arrête on a fait vous le
souhaitez les études montrent que c'est
possible ou que
sais-je donc le il y a il y a un accord
sur ce projet et à ce moment-là tous
ceux qui s'y opposeront devront
exactement prouver le contraire après il
y a il y a un ordre judiciaire hein mais
c'est c'est autre chose mais mais je
pense que ce couple préfet président
d'exécutif quel qu'il soit sur sur cette
base là avec une grande liberté avec
évidemment des régimes de responsabilité
mais vous le connaissez ça ça très bien
des régime de responsabilité pénale
alléger merci euh cher éc alors nous
avons quatre demandes de prise de parole
chacun disposant d'une montre ou d'un
téléphone qui lui indique l' voilà je
vous laisse
apprécier nos marches de manœuvre donc
pierre Pierre Jean puis Cédric chevalier
donc voilà une série de deux et Fabrice
Jie qui est
là comment je t' appelis c'est très bien
aussi voilà ben faisons cela faisons
cela et HERV quand je dis qu'il me
contredit
jamais voilà donc Pierre Jean merci
merci Madame présidente monsieur le
ministre juste pour pour revenir sur ce
que vous avez dit je je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous sur le
sujet de l'organisation libre de
certaines compét je vous donne quand
vous voulez un exemple d'une commune de
mon territoire de 1600 habitants sur
laquelle vous avez 5 structur qui
s'occupent de la même compétence ça ne
marche absolument pas et on parle de la
compétence tourisme pour le coup celle
que vous évoqueiez il y a la Région le
Département la gllo la commune qui l'a
gardé parce qu'elle a un casino sur son
territoire donc elle peut garder la
compétence tourisme et elle est intégré
dans un parc donc le parc s'en occupe
aussi vous avez C intervenants qui g le
tourisme ça ne fonctionne pas
idem que il y aurait un sujet à aborder
aussi c'est celui des cités scolaires où
vous avez une cohabitation département
région au sein d'une même structure qui
quand elles ne sont pas phasées
correctement pour faire notamment des
travaux et ben ça ne marche pas et là on
a un lien aussi avec le l'élu puisqu'on
oblige dans les cités scolaires les
élus les élus à faire des doubles
conseil
d'administrationour ah ben sur le
tourisme j'indiquerai clairement
j'indiquerai clairement où doit être
logée la
compétence pour moi c'est soit l'interco
soit l'interco que la région garde une
partie de la compétence tourisme pour le
spectre national ça me choque pas mais
après c'est à l'interco enfin
sincèrement on a on a voulu garder un
petit peu on a saupoudré et à l'arrivée
ça ne marche pas ça ne marche pas sur
les cités scolaires monsieur le ministre
juste un truc rapide mais aujourd'hui on
oblige les élus à faire deux conseils
d'administration l'un après l'autre pour
répéter exactement les mêmes choses
parce que la loi
l'oblige on passe des heures en conseil
d'administration pour se dire la même
chose mais on n pas le droit de faire
tout en même temps et on est dans les
mêmes dans la même enceinte dans la même
cité scolaire sauf que d'un côté le
département de l'autre il y a la région
sur les finances je trouve que ce qui
fatigue les maires et ce qui participe à
l'usure et au non renouvellement aussi
de des élus locaux c'est finalement
cette comp excité enfin quand on arrive
dans une commune on vient d'être élu si
on n pas baigné dans la politique ce qui
était mon cas j'avais mon boulot je me
suis présenté j'étais élu ils ont fait
le bon choix
[Musique]
maisoup et ben écoutez j'ai fait
l'inverse j'ai pas forcément mais bon ou
alors ils en avent très marre de du
prédécesseur bon on arrive dans dans
dans le fauteuil de mer on s'aperçoit
que finalement bah pour réaliser son
programme ça va être la NASA parce que
faut comprendre le fonctionnement au
niveau des financements c'est un truc
c'est j'emploirai pas le terme parce que
je sais pas si si on est filmé ou pas
mais enfin bon si on est c'est compliqué
oui nous le sommes alors je l'emploierai
pas non c'est non c'est incompréhensible
voilà ça c'est poli ça passe bien c'est
incompréhensible mais c'est une usine à
gaz une usine à gaz et moi j'ai la
chance d'être dans une région où toutes
les strates finanent la Région le
Département laglo mais là il y a un
principe d'inéquité quand on est maire
d'une commune dans une région où les les
collectivités partenaires ne financent
pas est-ce que c'est normal c'est-à-dire
que est-ce que le maire d'une région de
Verne
ronalpe a de facto plus de pouvoir pour
réaliser son mandat parce que plus
d'argent des collectivités partenaires
que c d'une région voisine qui se verra
pas accompagné ni par le Département
parce que c'est un choix politique ni
par la région mais mais ça c'est un vrai
sujet de fond et pour moi la
simplification des compétences et
le le fait aussi que nous arrivions à
motivier à motiver pardon des maèires à
s'engager ça vient par des choses très
simples à leur dire vous avez un budget
en début de mandat de temps et tout est
compris dedans après aller faire la
quête mais c'est insupportable et quand
on a un boulot en parallèle parce que
c'est quand même le les maèes ruraux ont
tous un boulot en parallèle faut trouver
du temps euh sur sa semaine de travail
pour aller aux réunions des uns des
autres pour aller demander des
subventions nous on a de la nous on a de
la chance nous sommes très bien
accompagné en région Vern Ronal parout
le monde Hervé mon collègue du
département on siége ensemble on sait
très bien que là-dessus l'argent public
il est au rendez-vous quand il faut
faire mais quand on a un boulot on peut
pas s'absenter tout le temps de son
travail pour aller à des réunions
chercher des subventions et et sur les
compétences dernier point parce qu'en
ruralité c'est quand même assez mal vécu
ces transfers de compétences pourraient
aussi s'apparenter je vais revenir sur
le sujet de l'eau qui a été évoqué en
zone hyper rurale euh en fait le
transfert de l'eau il y a deux sujets
que quand on est dans une aglo ou dans
une grosse collectivité que ça a été
transféré bon c'est fait on en parle
plus on y revient pas dessus ok quand on
est en communauté de commune rural
est-ce qu'on aurait pas pu réfléchir à
un système parce qu'on sait que là on
est en train de euh vraiment de de
frustrer les maires en leur enlevant
cette compétence souvent qui à laquelle
ils étaient très attachés est-ce qu'on
aurait pas pu laisser une liberté au
choix au libre arbitre he des présidents
de communauté de commune et de leur
conseil communautaire en signant un deal
sur je je fais vite je fais vite en
signant un deal sur la performance de
réseau ouais ouais je finis sur la
performance de réseau en disant bah
voilà l'ingénierie sera logée en
communauté de commune vous vous engagez
sur un meilleur rendement du réseau mais
vous laissez les budgets en commune et
enfin et c'est le dernier François je te
promets je te le jure J on va vérifier
vas-y ces mauvais transfers de
compétences sont des incidences sur
l'économie loc
et quand on transfère mal on s'aperçoit
aujourd'hui que souvent les
collectivités redélèguent à des sociétés
privées énormes voilà qui en réalité tue
l'économie locale parce qu'on a juste
rajouté une strate qui n'est pas
administrative mais privée mais ça tue
l'économie locale parce que le petit
pelteur qui bosse dans la commune il
peut plus il est sous-traitant
maintenant et tout ça on le tue
notamment en zone rurale merci désolé un
peu long une grande indulgence
chers alors Cédric et patri J roi de la
concision et nous avons aussi
Hervé qui Hervé Renault qui souhaite
parler donc Patrice et enfin Cédric
Patrice ETV voilà on a prévenu votre
rendez-vous suivant que on vous fera un
mot d'excuse monsieur alors merci madame
la présidente monsieur le ministre
Patrice je vais je vais essayer de faire
court parce que Pierre Jean a appris
beaucoup première chose en fait mais
vous l'avez plus ou moins abordé c'est
la clarification dans la clarification
c'est le fait finalement de pas remettre
en cause à aucun moment le millefeuille
territorial je je sens derrière vos
l'ensemble de réponses que c'est pas une
une piste que vous avez de dire est-ce
qu'on supprime carrément un certain
nombre de strat je voilà mais je
voudrais revenir sur le PCI parce que
Mathieu Darna en a parlé tout à l'heure
il a il a fait allusion à une une
interco XXL que je connais
particulièrement bien celle du Grand
rince pour y avoir été vice-président et
également maire de cette dans CCO moi il
y a deux choses alors effectivement
c'est ça fonctionne bien ça fonctionne
bien aussi parce que bon déjà comme on
est filmé je vais pouvoir le dire c'est
c'était très bien présidé notamment par
Catherine Vrin don je je profite
l'occasion pour le dire d'accord ouais
ouais ça ça ça ça peut aider non le
deuxième l'élément l'élément parce que
les EPCI pour pour regarder quel que
soit d'ailleurs les tailles ce qui ça
éloigne certes les maires mais ça
éloigne aussi les conseils municipaux et
je crois qu'il faut qu'on fasse
extrêmement attention parce que le maire
est quand même issu des conseils
municipaux et donc des facto en retirant
des compétences et cette proximit qui
était lié aussi avec les les conseillers
municipaux ça ça joue le deuxième c'est
que pourquoi ça a fonctionné dans le PCI
du du Grand rince parce que même si ça
fonctionne bien il y a quand même des
choses qui sont encore par parfait
notamment sur la notion de compétence
parce que voilà c'est qu'il y avait
aussi une charte de gouvernance je me
permets et qu'on a mis en place que la
présidente avait mis en place et
notamment avec une forme qui n'a jamais
été utilisé de droit de vet de droit de
vetto des maires sur des projets qui
concerneraient leur commune alors en ce
moment on est en train de traiter du
pluh vous avourez que est-ce que un
droit de vetto sur un pluh voilà mais ça
a permis en tout cas de renforcer une
forme de contrat de confiance entre les
maires et le PCI et deuxième élément je
pense qu'à un moment donné c'est
peut-être une piste que vous évoquerez
c'est la taille en fait les EPCI aussi
ont été pour certains ça a été un peu
des mariages forcés et c'est pas
forcément le reflet d'une communauté de
destin ou d'une envie partagé de
travailler sur un territoire et la
question que je vous pose c'est est-ce
que c'est un élément parmi les choses à
modifié de ces critères de taille plus
liés à des envies de travailler ensemble
alors même si ça parfois ça force ou en
tout cas à des réalités territoriales
qui nous sont imposé non pas par les
compétences mais par les par nos
concitoyens eux-mêmes voilà j'ai fait
cour merci Patrice puis notre collègue
HERV merci Madame présidente monsieur le
ministre merci pour cet échange euh vous
avez évoqué le fait enfin priori de de
ne pas toucher les différentes restat
mais la question qui peut se poser c'est
la divitalisation de certaines strates
ça avait été un projet d'un ministre
d'un autre gouvernement et donc tout ça
me conduit à à questionner en fait ou ça
nous conduit à questionner le cadre
d'organisation de la société d'une
manière générale le cardre politique et
philosophique on ne sait on a essayé
d'organiser la société au cours de ces
dernières décennies dans des logique de
massification de concentration qui ont
conduit à ce que les banques nationales
et internationales mettent à la Palade
en 2008 nous conduit à ce que les
plateformes des grandes surfaces
déterminent les prix et ce qui nous a
conduit à faire ces grandes institutions
qui créent de la distance avec
l'administré et le citoyen la vraie
question c'est est-ce qu'il y a pas à
s'interroger sur une organisation de la
société plutôt en réseau une approche
réticulaire de cette organisation on
nous dit au surplu que les technologies
aujourd'hui le permettent et la question
de la GO gouvernance de ces réseaux de
collectivité est-être un sujet sur
lequel nous pourrions essayer de
travailler en tout cas pour ce qui me
concerne j'essaie d'y réfléchir
s'agissant des compétences moi je suis
comme la collègue plutôt pour l'approche
en terme de compétenence générale pour
l'ensemble des collectivités d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui il y a des collectivités qui
interviennent en dehors de leurs
compétences on est dans une insécurité
juridique réelle et il y a une
incapacité à faire le contrôle de
qualité qui permettrait d'éviter
effectivement ces situations en tout cas
me permettrait le le respect de la loi
mais comment on fait lorsque un niveau
de collectivité ou un niveau
institutionnel n'est pas est défaillant
je pense en particulier pourquoi les
départements les communes mettent en
place des centres de santé tout
simplement parce qu' une défaillance de
l'État qui a la compétence en la matière
quand des départements interviennent en
matière économique parce que et et ou
qui n'arrivent pas à intervenir parce
que la loi est là c'est un manque pour
les territoires moi j'ai mon expérience
maire d'une commune rurale président
d'une communauté de commune rurale et et
président d'un département rural
aujourd'hui la distance avec la région
et les anciennes régions même he qui
étaient beaucoup plus petites font que
les départements sont parfois la seule
collectivité en mesure à la fois sur le
plan humain et financier d'intervenir
pour porter le développement local et
économique en particulier sur ce qui
n'est pas la l'accompagnement des des
artisans des commerces et cetera du
territoire mais travailler à
l'accompagnement du développement des
TPE de leur installation l'échelle de la
région beaucoup trop loin mon exemple
par exemple c'est euh j'avais
d'excellentes relations avec le
président de la région à l'époque o il
s'agissait de la seule Bourgogne à
chaque fois où je suis allé le voir avec
des porteur de projet on a toujours des
solutions jamais il est venu me voir et
quel que soit sa bienveillance et son
intention pour me dire dis donc il y a
un truc formidable sur ton territoire il
faut qu'on y travaill et aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui se passe on a des grandes
régions qui travaillent et pourtant la
bourine franchconté n'est pas la plus
grande avec des procédures et des
grilles d'analyes et on n'est pas dans
l'accompagnement du développement dans
le fait d'identifier les ressources
locales qui permettent effectivement de
construire des projets développement moi
j'avais un projet quand j'étais
président du département sur des
ressources particulières du département
d'aller travailler sur les modèles
économiques de ces ressources d'aller
chercher les partenaires privés à
l'extérieur sauf que on nous a coupé en
fait les possibilités puisqu'il n'était
plus possible d' d'intervenir j'aais
simplement si on parle toujours des
financements croisés moi je parle de
financement complémentaire dans des
petites collectivités petite commune
petit petit département on a besoin de
mettre les moyens en communs pour
pouvoir financer en tout cas porter pour
réduire au maximum l'autofinancement des
porteurs de projet sur la question des
dotations juste un mot la question
aujourd'hui de l'inéquité quand même de
la répartition entre les les territoires
les plus urbains et et et les
territoires les plus ruraux est quand
même une réalité si on continue à
financer ce qui s'appelle les surcouts
effectivement de la concentration
urbaine il y a aucune raison que l'on
change comme disait un poète qui
m'accompagnait il n'y a que les que les
poissons morts qui vont au fil de l'eau
je pense que la politique c'est de
remonter le courant au au contraire
voilà j'auris d'autres choses à vous
dire merci en tout cas merci patri enfin
cher Hervé il paraît que nous gardons le
meilleur pour la fin donc voilà je t en
tout cas merci de ta tolérance voilà
merci Madame la présidence la contrainte
nîra la j'ai la concision si ce
ncellence cher Mathieu Darnaud et à
vous-même madame la Présidente non ravi
pour cette matinée j'espère que les
échanges seront inspirants
réciproquement je voulais simplement
revenir sur une notion qui me paraît
très importante c'est effectivement la
clarification en matière de compétence
et
que je relirai effectivement là je vous
suis sur les aspects de financement je
moi sur le principe de réalité je crois
pas chacun souhaite tout faire c'est
parce que chacun joue sur un certain
nombre de solidarité qu'ell peuvent être
humaines ou territorial notamment les
dos communes parce que il y a un certain
nombre d'interstice où des choses ne se
font pas ou alors il y a des
manques je le vois particulièrement pour
les
départements c'est vrai que les
départements aident les communes parce
qu'elles n'ont pas les moyens seul de
porter un certain nombre de projets aidé
aussi par la région et d'autres un
échelon de proximité qui on l'a vu sur
la répartition de la compétence par
exemple économique la région a pris un
certain nombre de compétences économique
mais sur l'aide au commerce sur un
certain nombre d'acteurs économique de
proximité personne n'a pris la place au
fond donc c'est aussi parce que il y a
bien aujourd'hui un manque de
financement parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a
un certain nombre de flou dans ce que
chacun doit faire euh que chacun
finalement porte ensemble ensemble un
certain nombre de préoccupations pour
combler
finalement la réalisation de de projets
voilà c'est c'est pas le le trop plein
au fond c'est peut-être parce qu'il y a
un certain nombre de manque et parce que
les compétences ne se retouchent pas
qu'au fond chacun bah monte au créneau
alors c'est vrai que ça fait un certain
nombre de démarches administratives mais
mais heureusement que la région aide
heureusement que l'interc aide que le
département qui qui est quand même
aujourd'hui pour les départements
j'aurais quand même
une un mot particulier aujourd'hui avec
des recettes qui sont tout à fait
aléatoires qui sont liées aujourd'hui un
levier fiscal indirect d'une fiscalité
indirecte les DMTO effectivement tout va
très bien contre le logement se porte
bien aujourd'hui c'est extrêmement
compliqué et des dépenses sociales qui
elles par contre sont à peu près
certaines et je crois que la situation
d'ailleurs ne va pas pouvoir durer très
longtemps sauf à vouloir tuer le
département mais à ce moment faudrait le
dire réellement voilà donc je je pense
quand même il y a dans cette forme de de
de
confusion pas simplement la volonté de
de de chacun de se mêler de tout mais au
contraire de porter ensemble un certain
nombre de projets pour qu'il puisse se
réaliser et notamment à destination de
nos populations à travers les élus
locaux les les les élus municipaux en
particulier qui recherchent 50 60
jusqu'à 80 % de financement sinon ces
projets ne se font pas tout
simplement cher Éric je vous en prie
j'ai pas réponse à tout hein d'abord
parce qu'il y a des
propositions je crois vraiment que une
compétence claire c'est une
responsabilité claire et après au fond
une démocratie qui s'emporte le mieux
c'est chaque derrière chaque strate il y
a des élections euh si une collectivité
ne remplit pas ses obligation à partir
du moment où l'électeur a à peu près
compris à force de communication que qui
est responsable de quoi bah l'électeur
il choisit hein il est c'est c'est lui
qui domine qui domine l'ensemble et au
fond la confusion c'est quand même à un
moment donné une confusion démocratique
et je pense que tout le monde a a y
perdre alors évidemment plus on est loin
plus plus plus c'est compliqué d'être
clair parce que quand vous êtes une
région si vous dites il a pas assez les
commerçants est-ce que ça changera
quelque chose au scrutin qui sera très
politique je ne sais pas mais enfin
quand même euh on a bien choisi ces
niveaux de ces niveaux de de de de de
responsabilité d'organisation et de
fonctionnement des politiques publiques
nous avons choisi le législateur a main
de fois organisé tout cela si après sur
le terrain tout le monde peut faire
comme il veut
je c'est quand même très gênant pour un
législateur quoi dans ce cas-là on fait
tout pour après on aurait pu dire tout
le monde fait comme il veut c'est un
autre sujet mais c'est pas du tout ce
que nous avons décidé depuis depuis les
les 30 dernières années au contraire
donc ce principe de responsabilité il
doit être fondamental vraiment euh et
euh et et tous les outils existent
c'estàd que si le département dit je
veux faire de l'économie parce que parce
que la région fait pas assez ou elle est
trop
loin oui euh dans ce cas-là euh vous
vous entendez avec le détenteur de la
compétence principal et et et il y a des
rapports de force qui se font parce que
c'est vie politique euh et et au fond
soit la région elle corrige et elle
décide de faire euh soit le département
il agit par délégation euh on sait de
les outils vous en avez parlé pendant
des heures et des heures de ces de ces
outils euh ils existent donc il y a des
possibilités euh il faut juste que la la
compétence dans dans l'état d'esprit de
chaque président de Région de chaque
président de département on parle de de
de grandes structures obligatoirement
chaque président de grandes de grandes
EPCI il y a du pouvoir parce qu'il y a
évidemment des moyens financiers il y a
quand même du pouvoir même si il y a des
temps durs et des temps plus faciles
enfin il y a du pouvoir et la capacité
de faire euh honnêtement je je je pense
que il faut consacrer le maximum de ces
moyens financiers aux compétences qui
sont les siennes quoi euh c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'on fait longtemps les
départements par les collèges et et les
régions par les lycées le le progrès est
phénoménal et je pense que il y a pas de
scénario contrefactuel mais si l'État
avait continué à s'en occuper je suis
pas sûr qu'on aurait un tel niveau de
qualité dans le domaine des collèges
dans le domaine des lycées dans tout
cela donc parce qu'on a concentré
beaucoup de moyens à un moment donné
c'est une politique construite pensée
extrêmement précise personne ne ne ne
finance à côté les collèges ou les
lycées même pas l'état il peut y avoir
des points de sur des sur du personnel
mais personne ne le fait pour une bonne
raison parce que personne ne le fait en
dehors du détenteur de cette compétence
c'est d' il ne supporterait pas
quelqu'un d'autre le fasse ce qui ce qui
serait bien naturel donc on doit pas
c'est pas après je crois pas au jardin
la français je le dis encore une fois au
contraire il faut qu'il y ait une vraie
capacité d'adaptation mais la capacité
d'adaptation elle vient aussi par ça par
la clarification plus on peut clarifier
plus à ce moment-là la norme nationale
qui qui qui qui régit cette compétence
devient
adaptable sinon c'est le bazar alors on
peut toujours faire toutes les
conférences que vous voulez sur le plan
local réunir tous les élus pour pour
dire alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait comment
on fait regardez le tourisme vous dites
ouais mais les communes mais normalement
c'est plutôt les intercommunalités
c'està dire que c'est plutôt les
intercommunalités après le département
il a une compétence touristique depuis
Matusalem et puis la région bah
l'attractivité du de la France pour un
chinois déjà la France il situe pas par
rapport à l'Europe donc la région machin
ou truc mais mais si c'est juste le
département ou la commune on peut pas y
arriver en dehors de Versailles donc il
faut que il faut que peut-être que
l'enchevêtrement l'empilement a un
intérêt euh chacun peut jouer mais c'est
sûr que s'il y en a trois ça doit
pouvoir fonctionner s'il y en a quatre
ça marche pas je suis d'accord mais je
remarque aucun élu n'a en réalité mis
sur la la table une répartition claire
de ces questions parce qu'au fond chacun
sen satisfait et que c'est un espace de
liberté d'organisation je suis moiême
président d'un office de tourisme donc
je vois à peu près cet empilement
mais je trouve
que voilà au niveau d'une
intercommunalité on sait quand on doit
s'adresser au département sur le plan du
tourisme ils font des choses que un
office peut pas faire et et la région
elle a tous les outils technologiques
nécessaires bon on trouve aussi il y a
aussi des parts de liberté peut-être
qu'on doit tenter de les
respecter voilà j'ai j'ai pas et quant
au retour de clause de compétence
général alors sauf si sauf si euh en
tout cas moi je je je suis libre de mes
propositions euh au président moi je ne
proposerait pas un retour aux clauses de
compétences général pour tout le monde à
tout moment euh c'est le contraire de la
clarification et et de
l'approfondissement de l'exercice d'une
compétence elles sont de plus en plus
compliquées ces compétences elles sont
de plus en plus professionnalisées il y
a de plus en plus
d'interlocuteurs et l'opinion publique
elle est de plus en plus pressante quel
que soit le le
sujet se disperser honnêement juste
parce qu'on considère que celui d'à côté
il a mal fait enfin c'est c'est c'est
pas
possible merci merci
beaucoup cher Eric merci à tous pour la
richesse des des questions et des points
de vue on voit bien que la chose est un
peu voilà il y a beaucoup de
différenciation on va le dire et je
prendrai euh deux exemples pour montrer
que le jardin la française définit sous
forme d'équation depuis Paris et
confronté à la réalité de la vie et que
je pense que parfois
l'organisation de de la mise en œuvre du
service public doit partir de la nature
du sujet plutôt qu'une définition hors
sol et je prendrai l'exemple du tourisme
ce que chacun dit est vrai je vais
prendre l'exemple du monts-michel qui
n'est pas dans ma région Bretagne vous
le savez bien le mont ouais voilà le
mais voilà mais le
monts-michel fait que vous avez beaucoup
de touristes japonais et naturellement
ce site qui est exceptionnel en matière
touristique fait que toute la côte nord
de l'île et Villain c'estàdire
saintmalot Dinard doit naturellement
s'organiser en matière de tourisme en
tenant compte de la logique du client
final qui est le tourisme donc on a
inventé ce qu'on appelle un tourisme de
destination et après il appartient aux
deux régions de travailler ensemble de
manière intelligente sur
l'économie tu expliquais que quand
toutes les collectivités interviennent
c'est compliqué moi j'ai une expérience
professionnelle un peu longue dans une
chambre de commerce et je me souviens de
réunion les chefs d'entreprise qui
voulait s'installer quelque part
disaient que il y a beaucoup plus de
fonctionnaires qui représentent l'entité
région l'entité agence de développement
et cetera que l'industriel qui se trouve
un peu perd et trop entouré
d'affection dernier petit point
peut-être dont on a parlé beaucoup avec
Rémi po la simplification et moi je
relie ça à la question des finances
locales nous sommes tu tu l'as rappelé
dans un pays qui a quelques milliards
d'euros de de déficit et que les
collectivités ont en même temps à
financer des service et que je pense que
quand on est dans une période de grande
frugalité budget
au-delà des dotations que l'on pourrait
aller chercher il faut aussi qu'on
puisse faire des économies et
sincèrement je pense que en matière de
normes on doit pouvoir alléger les
dépenses obligatoires des collectivités
entre 2017 et
2022 l'inflation normative a coûté 200
milliards 5 de dépenses obligatoirees
aux collectivités donc je pense qu'il
faut aussi qu'on s'attelle à cette tâche
que la norme elle ne rend pas forcément
intelligent en est efficace et elle est
très coûteuse et puis dernier point sur
ce qui relève des compétences régalienne
de l'État alors la sécurité la santé et
en même temps je pense on l'a vu pendant
la crise sanitaire il y a un niveau de
la compétence santé qui est régalien et
puis parfois la mise en œuvre qui peut
relever de territoire et je prends un
exemple à partir de ce que tu as
justement rappelé on voit bien
aujourd'hui que les bâtiments
scolaire lycé et collège ont été confiés
aux collectivités que ça marche plutôt
super bien et que je pense que dans
certaines région on évoque la
possibilité que sur la santé il pourra
en être de c'est on a une politique de
santé nationale qu'on remet pas en cause
mais que les bâtiments par exemple
pourraient être aussi confiés à à des
régions qui
pourrait en être enfin qui pourrait être
volontaire et puis dernier point qui
tient beaucoup au Sénat on a un discours
très simple c'est qui décide paye et que
nous nous sommes très insistants sur la
clause de revoyure qui sera une clause
de Revoy vraiment responsable entre
l'État et les collectivités dès lors que
des dispositifs législatifs au
règlementaire viennent surcharger le
financement d'une compétence qui a été
transférée à un moment il faut quand
même qu'on discute un peu du du sujet
euh donc voilà je ne serai pas plus long
vraiment 1LE merciis je crois que on a
eu la chance de pouvoir échanger très
librement avec toi merci merci beaucoup
ché merci de l'écoute
merci du travail que tu fais de cette
volonté partagée que nous avons de
l'efficacité de l'action publique
jusqu'au dernier kilomètre et la
conviction que le jardin à la français
qui est
magnifique doit aussi parfois comparé au
jardin à l'anglaise voilà un peu
différent mais qui a beaucoup de charme
et d'effic dans le château de chantillly
nous avons les
deux voilà donc on a bien fait de te
choisir pour cette mission merci cher
Erric merci beaucoup mes chers collègues
je vous rappelle que la semaine
prochaine nous avons un hors les murs
ass saut jeudi matin pour parler de
l'intelligence artificielle et des
territoires il nous seront accompagné de
de Monsieur Darnaud merci à tous merci
cher